[Music]
on this friday night russia on a war
footing urgent calls for the kremlin to
back down over ukraine or else it will
be met with swift
severe and a united response and
ottawa's new commitment to key
doctors facing discrimination they've
moved elsewhere because of the racism
the growing uproar after our exclusive
interview with the new brunswick doctor
as the fifth wave finally peaked
canada's top doctor on the positive
signs and plans for future vaccine doses
plus rest in paradise
a rock superstar is silenced
how meatloaf found his voice
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight jeff semple
[Music]
good evening and thank you for joining
us canada is sending more help to
ukraine amid growing fears that a
russian invasion is imminent ottawa is
providing a loan of 120 million dollars
the prime minister says those funds will
support ukraine's economic resilience
we're also exploring other options to
provide financial and other supports and
again
canada calls on russia to de-escalate
and engage in meaningful dialogue
talks between the u.s secretary of state
and his russian counterpart ended today
without any breakthrough and a pretty
frosty handshake
both sides did agree the talks should
continue but as jackson proskow explains
there's little hope of finding a
diplomatic solution
as russia released new video of military
drills and its buildup on ukraine's
doorstep
the country's foreign minister sat down
with the u.s secretary of state in
geneva seeking diplomatic deterrence
this was not negotiation but a candid
exchange of concerns and ideas
amid the unspoken threat of invasion
russia's vladimir putin wants major
concessions a withdrawal of nato from
former soviet states and guarantees
against future nato expansion including
into ukraine
the u.s will respond to those demands in
writing but is unlikely to concede and
has already vowed a swift and severe
response to any russian invasion
i hope the emotions will cool down but
there are no guarantees said russian
foreign minister sergey lavrov
in eastern ukraine the situation grows
more tense the u.s is deploying military
helicopters to the region more countries
are sending anti-tank weapons and
ammunition
putin though may still see an opening
with some nato members indicating
reluctance to respond to anything less
than a full-scale russian invasion
military
what measures will be taken will be
agreed among everyone in due course said
germany's new chancellor it's not just
what putin will accept it's just what
everybody else will accept fiona hill
was the top russia adviser to several
american presidents with putin's motives
uncertain and his goals unclear she says
avenues away from conflict look
increasingly slim putin seems to have
painted himself into a corner if there's
good news it's that both sides are still
talking and attempts at diplomacy show
no sign of slowing down the next step
could involve another direct
conversation between putin and u.s
president joe biden
jeff
jackson proskow in washington thanks
jackson
the u.s is also giving the green light
for the baltic states nato allies
estonia lithuania and latvia to send
their american-made weapons to support
ukraine canada as mentioned earlier is
sending financial aid and as michael
couture explains ottawa is also
exploring other options
at a time when ukraine needs military
might canada is sending money promising
up to 120 million dollars in loans to
counter russian aggression and
destabilization we're happy to be there
to reinforce the resilience and the
strength of ukraine's economy faced with
russian destabilization including
economic destabilization trudeau says
the loan was one of the top asks from
ukraine's leadership friday president
vladimir zelinsky sent a tweet to thanks
underlining the devotion to the spirit
of special partnership between our two
countries and trudeau had this message
from moscow any movement of russian
troops into ukraine will be absolutely
unacceptable and met with a clear
response from the international
community
but how strongly is canada willing to
respond canadian soldiers are already on
the ground in ukraine training their
troops as part of operation unifier
behind the scenes there is contingency
planning to take a more aggressive
stance
in an interview with mercedes stevenson
for sunday's edition of the west block
defense minister anita anan wouldn't
rule out sending weapons i'm working
with my cabinet colleagues on ways to
further support ukraine and i will have
more to say on those options some
believe adding further to ukraine's
arsenal has to be weighed against
whether the kremlin will regard it as
further provocation when diplomatic
resolutions are still possible weapons
shipments to ukraine are in a way a form
of escalation of the conflict
of course russia sees this as
also preparation for war and for
ukrainian canadians these are difficult
times there's a lot of stress there's a
feeling of helplessness people are just
uh you know
focused on doing uh what they can to
convince the canadian government on the
next steps
next steps like economic sanctions
against russia or weapons support for
ukraine mike lacrouter global news
ottawa
in new brunswick there are growing
concerns that a controversy including a
doctor is causing other medical
professionals to leave the province dr
genre bear angola says that he was
wrongly blamed for causing a covet-19
outbreak in the spring of 2020. ross
lord has more on the fallout in the
health community and why some say it
could undermine the province's
immigration efforts
in campbellton new brunswick a health
care system that was struggling before
the pandemic has become even more
shorthanded four doctors have moved away
since 2020 leaving thousands of patients
without a family doctor the most notable
departure dr jean robert angola he was
accused of breaking covet 19 lockdown
rules and of spreading the virus to his
patients
there are physicians who feel very
uncomfortable with the situation and
some have actually
i don't know if the
dr nagola case specifically did this but
they they've moved elsewhere because of
the racism that they've experienced
angola is suing that he runs to a
government the rcmp and facebook
alleging he was falsely scapegoated
after providing health care in hamilton
for seven years who attack you
your patients
the populations
the government
your hospitals dr angola is not fighting
for justice alone he has the support of
a large number of colleagues more than
600 doctors across canada wrote a letter
to new brunswick premier blaine higgs
asking higgs to apologize for his part
in two investigations of angola both of
which were dropped advocates for
immigrants fear the treatment of dr
angola an immigrant from congo could
undermine new brunswick's ambitious
efforts to bring in 10 000 newcomers per
year to fill labor market shortages
well it's definitely bad pr it doesn't
help and the moment that you
do things differently or bad
you're going to be rejecting you
that's not what true inclusion means to
me
that's not what we stand for as
canadians and brunswickers premier higgs
suggests there's nothing to be afraid of
well i would suggest that if all the
facts come out in a uh
in in a proper hearing and and if it has
to be a court challenge then then then
that's i guess where it's headed
uh that will allay those fears meanwhile
the province has made an urgent plea for
doctors who can help with new
brunswick's pandemic response
ross lord global news campbellton new
brunswick
to the pandemic now and hopeful signs
that the omicron fueled fifth wave may
have peaked canada's top doctor says
case counts test positivity and
wastewater surveillance all show that
infections are falling but theresa tam
also warns that hospitalization rates
and deaths remain high over the past
week an average of over 10 000 people
with covert 19 were being treated in our
hospitals each day surpassing peak daily
numbers for all previous waves of the
pandemic
this includes over 1100 people in
intensive care units which is higher
than all but the third wave peak
tam says those numbers underscore the
importance of vaccinations to help
reduce the strain on hospitals but if
this latest wave has finally peaked what
will that mean for canada's vaccination
strategy moving forward jamie morocco
has more on the plans for booster shots
more canadians have been infected with
covid19 during this wave than any before
but more have also been vaccinated it's
better to be secure than you know the
latest data showed just over a third of
canadians already have a third dose but
new ipsos polling conducted for global
news reveals many aren't eager to get
additional shots beyond that more than
half 56 percent express some concern and
wonder how many more we may need i think
it's ridiculous to think that we should
be getting you know a vaccine every four
or six months
you know indefinitely data from israel
found fourth doses less effective
against omicron experts here agree
immunocompromised people warrant an
additional boost but there isn't a clear
consensus for everyone else we need to
see now
what will happen to
protection over time
with third doses vaccine manufacturers
aren't waiting moderna says it hopes to
produce a shot capable of tackling
multiple variants the point of actually
creating boosters that have different
vaccine sort of
strains inside of them is to actually
shock your immune system a little bit
and get it to grow and broaden its
immune response the company is also in
phase 2 trials for a combined flu covet
rsv vaccine but dr peter hotez one of
the developers of a patent-free coven
vaccine formula says until we vaccinate
the world new mutations will emerge
mother nature's not being coy with us
she's telling us what she's going to do
because she's done it twice it's going
to happen again we are going to have
another major variant of concern
canada's top doctor says we aren't ready
to commit to a new vaccine strategy i
think the global opinion at this point
is that the omicron virus is going to be
with us for some time
so we do need to take a longer term
approach waiting for more data to make a
decision that will ultimately impact
canadians health for years to come jamie
morrocker global news toronto
british columbia has announced a shift
in its response to the pandemic bc's
chief public health officer says contact
tracing is no longer effective and
everyone should assume that they've been
a close contact of someone with the
virus dr bonnie henry says the province
will manage covet 19 like it does other
illnesses such as the common cold
we cannot eliminate all risk and i think
that's something that we we need to
understand and accept as this virus has
changed and has become part of what we
will be living with for years to come
and we have some breaking news now out
of mexico where there are reports a
canadian tourist has been shot and
killed at a resort two other canadians
were reportedly also injured in that
shooting it happened today at a resort
south of playa del carmen accord
according to the state's security chief
he tweeted that the gunman was also a
guest and that police are now hunting
for that suspect right now global
affairs canada says it is aware of the
reports but because of privacy concerns
is not releasing any other information
and we're learning more tonight about
the circumstances surrounding the tragic
deaths of four people including a baby
near the u.s border in manitoba court
documents suggest the suspect in the
alleged human smuggling operation may
have been part of three other cases
brittany greenslade reports
their last hours were spent on a
treacherous journey attempting to cross
into the u.s from manitoba and police
say the man accused of facilitating it
is 47-year-old steve shand
court documents reveal u.s homeland
security believes this is part of a
larger human smuggling operation
involving shand he's accused of
smuggling 11 indian foreign nationals
across the border this week including
the four who died in the extreme cold
when you're faced with no other choices
sometimes you're forced to make
choices that
are dangerous shand was arrested while
driving a 15 passenger van with two of
the migrants inside five others were
picked up walking they each had what
appeared to be new black in color winter
coats with fur trimmed hoods black
gloves black balaclavas and insulated
rubber boots according to court
documents
u.s authorities suspect shand is
connected to three other recent
smuggling incidents
in one case three sets of footprints
were found all made by the same brand of
boots on another occasion a backpack
with a price tag showing a value in
rupees a cost that many in desperation
still pay
this week with their lives
and it's possible no one will be held
accountable here even though some of the
activity had taken place in canada
it's unlikely that there would be a
prosecution
in canada shand is expected to appear in
federal court monday
brittany greenslade global news winnipeg
the alberta premier's pandemic plans
coming up our interview with jason
kenney including his blunt assessment of
canada's environment
[Music]
minister alberta premier jason kenney
says there are signs that province has
reached and surpassed its peak of covid
19 cases in the fifth wave but he's also
warning the record high hospitalizations
are rising and putting a huge strain on
health care resources our mercedes
stevenson sat down with jason kenny
today so mercedes what did he have to
say about when the restrictions will end
well jeff he said that he thinks covid
will come back but the pandemic won't he
believes it will move into an endemic
rather than a pandemic which is more
like the annual flu so he sounds pretty
optimistic and that's interesting
because we remember the experience that
he had after the summer and fall when he
declared the best summer ever alberta
opened up and then they had this
dramatic wave of covet 19. the premier
says the difference between then and now
is the level of vaccination in the
summer it was only around 75 percent of
albertans he says it's now closer to 90
percent and that is the difference
between omicron and the delta variant
for albertans take a listen to what he
had to say about when he thinks all
restrictions will lift which is what the
united kingdom is doing right now
so we will proceed uh cautiously and
prudently but i think we will be in a
position to substantially re release uh
public health measures that we have in
the in this province which are far less
stringent than for example in in central
canada
and um and to move because we have to
just
learn to live with this
jeff premier kenny thinks that the
height of those hospitalizations is
likely to be around the end of january
or beginning of february so after that
would be when he's looking at lifting
restrictions
interesting and on a separate note we've
also heard kenny express concerns about
the federal government's plans to phase
out fossil fuel subsidies so what did he
have to say about that today
yeah well environment minister steven
gilbeau had said that in an interview
they're looking to phase out fossil fuel
subsidies in about two years jason
kenney says that's news to him and he
had a pretty strong term to describe the
new federal environment minister listen
to this
well if that is in fact the case they
haven't said that to us bluntly but
there's certainly a lot of suggestions
that they i mean the appointment of
stephen gebo a a
former
environmental extremist
to the environment ministry is very
concerning to us
so a former environmental extremist
we'll see what the federal government's
response to that is it gives you a sense
of the tensions jeff kenney says that
even though there is a difficult
relationship at times with ottawa on
things like oil and gas and climate
change they continue to work together to
try to deal with the covet 19 situation
as you know he has a very different view
on things like truckers being vaccinated
and we'll explore all of that on the
west block with him on sunday
looking forward to that
mercedes-stevenson in ottawa thanks
so now i look at the healthy side of the
menu what's on here
salmon
still ahead remembering a lifetime of
laughs with the late louie anderson
[Music]
a young boston bruins fan got quite the
surprise from an nhl star last night
hey what's up this is bm63 just walking
off from uh warm-ups
hope i don't know whose phone this is
but uh
hope you have a lot of fun tonight
because i know i'm going to
that is halifax board brad marchand
recording a message on a fan's phone
following the pre-game skate now the
night didn't quite go as planned
marchand left the game after taking a
big hit but his bruins did defeat the
visiting washington capitals 4-3
pop superstar adele broke down in tears
as she announced that she's postponing
her highly anticipated las vegas
residency
my show ain't ready
we've tried absolutely everything that
we can
to put it together in time and for it to
be good enough for you but we've been
absolutely destroyed by
delivery delays and covet
adele made the emotional announcement on
instagram adding that half of her team
has covet 19 the 24-date residency was
supposed to kick off at caesar's palace
tonight
up next from his distinct singing voice
to the silver screen remembering
meatloaf
[Music]
louis anderson whose comedy and acting
career spanned more than four decades
has died
the only time i want to eat salmon
is when i'm watching the animal planet
and a grizzly plucks one from a stream
i think to myself
i should give salmon another try
he makes it look so delicious
anderson got his big break as a stand-up
comic in the 80s but became a regular on
tv with his cartoon series life with
louis anderson was nominated for an emmy
four times and won in 2016 for his role
on baskets anderson was 68 years old
and one of rock music's biggest stars
has also died meatloaf the singer and
actor best known for the album bad out
of hell was 74. mike draulie has more on
his rock and roll legacy
was there anybody quite like meatloaf he
was a force in everything he did
uniquely flamboyant and gifted with the
voice that set him apart
he had a peculiar kind of voice he was
known as a helden tenor
helden tenor uh
translates as heroic tenor and it's the
kind of voice that you know you would
need in a
vagnarian opera the story he liked to
tell was that he only discovered he
could sing after being hit in the head
by a 12 pound shot put at a high school
track meet
the man born marvin leah day was a
natural storyteller and after moving to
hollywood as meatloaf a nickname he
picked up playing football in high
school the spotlight found him
[Music]
as the biker from the freezer in the
rocky horror picture show he caught the
attention of composer jim steinman
together they would create bad out of
hell one of the best selling albums of
all time
meatloaf owned the 70s and then
disappeared in the 1980s after he lost
his voice suffered a nervous breakdown
and had a falling out with steinman i
have heard his relationship with jim
simon described as a grumpy old married
couple they needed each other but
sometimes they just couldn't stand each
other and they would fight but
eventually they would make up and get
back to work
in the early 90s they reunited for
meatloaf's biggest hit
and he rediscovered his love of acting
my name is bob bob
he appeared in 65 films and kept touring
refusing to stop even after collapsing
on stage because with meatloaf there was
always another act
microlight global news toronto
and that is global national for this
friday i'm jeff semple tonight's your
canada is the national war memorial in
ottawa thanks for watching have a great
night
[Applause]
[Music]
you